harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman and ceo of empowerment and
inclusion capital
morgan ortegas former state department
spokesperson and steve hayes editor of
the dispatch
uh panel welcome a lot of me to dive
into morgan i'll start with you because
of your involvement with the last state
department the last administration what
did you make of the conversation about
denuclearizing the peninsula where we
stand where the where the relationships
are
tonight so you're right shannon i've
been through a lot of those press
conferences and i wrote down some notes
here
first of all there is this could have
been in many ways a mike pompeo press
conference
a lot of the key words and phrases that
we have used amongst many
administrations were there we talked
about shared future
shared values what's really important
here is that president biden
and moon committed to the complete
denuclearization
and that's really important because we
saw strategic patience was the
philosophy that the obama administration
pursued
obviously we went for a bigger grand
bargain in the trump
administration but i think two big
things that uh
that are coming out of this has been
reported that the biden team are going
to use the basis of the singapore summit
that was between trump
and kim jong-un the first time ever at
the leader level
that kim jong-un that a leader of north
korea committed to complete
denuclearization so president biden may
be changing the style
by which he operates with dprk but he
certainly is using very similar language
very similar substance
one thing i would say that was really
missing though in this whole
conversation that was just in a glaring
omission to me
was there was no mention of china uh
significantly at all
and i don't know how you have president
moon uh
at the white house and and how you don't
have a major announcement on
the policy towards china from these two
major allies
big omission well and harold they did
have some discussion of taiwan and where
the two
are on discussing these issues south
korea and the u.s that's a critical
issue as well
no doubt i think that president biden
showed
the real difference in his style and his
approach
to governing particularly foreign policy
here's a president with 40 years of
experience
foreign policy experience every
president is an answer to his and one
day we'll say her predecessor
this president brings more experience in
government
than any president in my lifetime and i
would argue as much as any president has
brought
he recommitted uh and made clear our
commitment to a two-state solution
he made clears morgan said very well the
commitment to a denuclearized
region but i think more so than anything
when he said that he has
private conversations with leaders and
he takes leaders at their word
as much as there's a stylistic
difference there's a bit of a
substantive difference there
as well i think with him and his
predecessor i was hoping to hear
something on china i don't think the
omission
uh is quite as glaring as my as my good
friend thinks uh it would have been it
would have been nice to hear more there
but i was really pleased just to see the
dynamic between
these two presidents and very quickly
steve
the mention there that harold made of
the previous administration uh
go back several administrations and
north korea including the one that
president biden when he was vice
president was part of
that continues that problem continues to
foment over decades
incredibly difficult uh problem to solve
and you heard joe biden say
the past four administrations haven't
gotten it done i was struck by the the
the major difference that he said he was
not going to meet with kim jong-un we
saw president trump
in sort of theatrical photo op uh
meetings
joe biden made pretty clear that that's
not going to happen under his watch
if he doesn't want to give any
legitimacy very quickly before we get
cut off
okay we'll get back to you guys